わぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁ!
おぉ～
うえぇぇぇ...
こんにちは!　はじめしゃちょーです!
よみうりランドの方に遊びに来ているんですけども、
このよみうりランドの敷地内に
新しいエリアができたということで
本日ちょっと遊びに来ております。
その名もこちら
「グッジョバ!!」でございま～す
こちらの「グッジョバ!!」には
モノづくりに関する15種の
アトラクションがありまして、
生活に密着した、子供たちが親しみやすい
の、4つの工場から成り立っています。
もう沢山のアトラクションがあるのでちょっと色々
楽しんで遊んでいきたいと思います！
では行きましょう
見えて来ました?
あ、こちらですね
カーフィクチュリー(CAR factory)
サポーテッドバイ(Saported by)
二ッスィン(Nissan)
日産ですねw
はい、という訳で
無事着きました、「カスタムガレージ」でございま～す。
ここでは主に
自動車のモノづくりを体験できるということでちょっと
実際に車を作るのかな？
とりあえず実際にやってみましょう。
で、各工場になんですけども、
サポート企業さんや
パートナー企業さんがついてまして、
その各メーカーさんのモノづくりを
体感できるみたいです。
ガイド) は～い、こんにちは～
あーこんにちは、
ガイド) お待ちしておりましたー
あ～りがとうございます
おぉお！
ガイド) これからですね、
ガイド) お兄さんにはこの車を
ガイド) これから組み立てて頂きたいと思います。
おぉお。
早速組み立てていきまっしょう
と言いたい所なんですけども、
そう、ここは
Factory。
ヘルメットを被ってないと、
とても危険です、なので
ちょっと僕はこのここからは
ちょっとヘルメットを着けて作業に入ります。
そうね特別な、特殊なヘルメットを
準備...してｗもらったんでｗｗ
っはーーぁ↑
何ですかこれｗｗｗ
これを被って、
作業に入りたいと思います。
では早速やっていきましょう。
じゃまずは
ボンネットフードから付けていきましょう。
結構ありますよね。
あぁでも何かとりあえず色的に
これがカッコいいからこれにしましょう。
お、来たんじゃないですかこれ。
じゃ次はフロントライトいきましょう。
や絶対に男はこれでしょう。
これでそぅ
絶対これですよ。
はぁぁぁぁっ！
できました。
はいという訳でここからは
ネジ締めのようです。
おぉぉっ！
(変な笑顔タイム)
できました！
ガイド) 完成で～す
ありがとざま～す
皆さん是非実際足を運んで、
やってみてください。
はい、というわけでやって参りました～。
次はこちらですね。
スピンランウェイ。
これぁファッションの、
Factoryでございます。
では早速、やっていきましょう。
ガイド) こちら、抜けて頂きますと、
ガイド) ちょっと、違う世界です。(意味深)
うわ、すご。
ガイド) こちらのモニターは、
はい
ガイド) 「WORLD」さんのデザイナーさんが
ガイド) 実際に描いてくださった、
へぇ～
ガイド) 洋服ですね。
ガイド) ボタン押すと、
ガイド) このように。
ガイド) パシャッと。
機械) 撮ります
ガイド) すごくちょっとｗ近いかもｗｗ
機械) カシャァ
あぁ～なるほど。
そういうことｗですねｗｗ
お、おっとぉ～
見えて来た。
見えて来たぞぉ
ちょっとジェットコースターチックな物が。
ありました。
はいぃ、乗ります。
では早速、乗っていきましょう。
よし来ましたよ、おおっとっとぉ？
うおぉ、すごぉい。
色んな物がありますね。
あPUSH！
うっ冷たい
ぷっぷっぷっぷっぷぅ
おっ、コーディネートの時間です。
機械) ボタンを押して、
はい
機械) コーディネートを選んでね☆
機械) 決定！
はぁい。
機械) まぁずは、トップスだよ。
ジャンプ！
機械) 息を合わせてね
ジャンプ。
ジャンプ
機械) 良く見てね。
ジャンプ(疲)
ジャンp(疲)
終わってしまった。
機械) さあーどんなコーディネートが
機械) 出来たかはお楽しみ。
おぉ？
機械) スリー、トゥー、
おっ？
はじめ・機械) ワン
機械) スピィィィィン
えぇっ？
機械) ランウェイ！
へっぱぁぁぁぁぁ！
ホッホォー↑
ホウェヴェヴェヴァヴァヴァ
ほ、ほ、ほ、ほ、ほ、ほ。
おん、かわいい。
機械) ...コーディネート、完成だね☆
はい、という訳で無事()
ファッションコーディネートが完了しましたが
ジェットコースターだけは苦手なのでちょっと...
厳しいものがありました。
すごい今迫力満点で
楽しかったです
是非皆さんもやってみてください！
では！次のアトラクションにいきまっしょう。
フードのFactoryでございます。
まあ見て分かる通り、
日清さんの「U.F.O.」をテーマにした
Factoryです。
ではちっと中の方入っていきましょう。
「My U.F.O. Factory」という事で、
聞いた話によると
自分の、「My U.F.O」が作れるみたいな
話を聞いたので、
ちょっと行ってみましょう。
ガイド) こちらの、デザインシートという物を、一枚。
ガイド) お取りください。
ガイド) こちらですね、11種類ございまして、
ガイド) 中にはキラキラした物や、
ガイド) 黒い物がありますので
ガイド) そちらはとってもレアですので、
ろぉっ？
ガイド) はい出たら、めっちゃラッキーです。
わぁ当てたい所だずスね。
うぇ？当たりですか？
ガイド) おめでとうございますぅ↑
ガイド) はいこちらラッキーな当たりですぅ↑
え！？マジですか？
やったぁありがとうございます。
さここからデザインを作っていくみたいですが、
えぇんヤバい、自由に描くって言われたら
また難しいスねぇ
ちと今カメラマンをしてくださってる方
描きま～す
良い感じ。
剣持たせてあげます
出来ました！どうでしょうかぁ
カメラマン) はい、見せてください。
はい。
HiROKiさんをイメージしたU.F.O.です。
どどん
ガイド) ありがとうございま～
ガイド) とっても素敵な絵(?)、ありがとうございます。
あ～、ありがとうございます。
褒められました。
良かったです。
ありがとうございます
ほい。
ガイド) はいっ！機械ご注目です。
うをぉ
ガイド) カップが流れてきて。
ガイド) シュッと。
ガイド) ぁ～い、このようにソースが入りました。
ガイド) こちらの、12種類の具材の中から、
ガイド) お好きな物を4つ！お選びください。
4つ。はい。
ポテト。
ガイド) ポテト。
はい。
ガイド) 二つ目をを選びくださぁ～ぃ↑
ポテトで。
ガイド) ポテトですね？かしこまりましたぁ～
ガイド) 三つ目をお選びくださぁい。
っとぉ、結構色々種類があるので、
ガイド) はい。
あポテトで～
ガイド) あ、ポテトですねw
ガイド) 最後にもう一つ、お選びくださぁい。
キャベツでぇ～
はい、という訳で無事(?)、完成しました～
すごい(?)
HAHAHAHAｗｗ
???「いやっふぅ」
はいという訳で次のアトラクションです。
こちら。
SKYパト。
ALSOKさんの「SKYパト」で～す
まあこれスカイパトロ－ルという意味がある...まして、
この...アトラクション、このエリア内を、
パトロ－ルするという意味で、
ALSOKさんのこの「SKYパト」というのがあるみたいです。
まあゆったりした乗り物みたいなので
ちょっと、のんびりと、楽しんでみようかと思います。
では早速行ってみましょ～う
1、2、3、4、
ALSO...
では、行って来ます。
機械) レッツ...
パトロールゥゥゥ
おおヤバい、始まった。
すごい、景色がすご～い
ヤカンがある。ここにヤカンが。
ぐるっと見渡してたんで良かったです。
では次行ってみましょう。
はいということで次はこちら。
キャンパスチャレンジということで
コクヨさんのアトラクションのコーナーでございます。
有名なキャンパスノートの。
コクヨさんです。
じゃあちょと中入ってみましょう。
ノートを作る工程を。
ゲームとしてやっていく感じです。
でぁまず。
一個目、行きましょう。
色とボタンを。
色と数字を押せば、クリアということで。
っし、カモン！
ゴトン
痛っ！
機械) チャレンジスタートー
7番7番7番の、7番。7番。7番7番。
78394。
機械) ピポーン
78394の7。
8。
機械) ピポーン、20秒経過。
機械) ピポーン
あれ、もったっさった39。
機械) ピピー
やったぁ！
来たぞぉ
ふぅっ↑
全部消えてますよ！
嬉しいんですけど。
機械) チャレンジスタート！
機械) 3...2...1...
機械) ピピー
あっ、次行かなきゃ。
うっしょぉ！
あっ...おっ...
ぅえっ？
ははは、ちょっと早かった
風) ッスゥゥゥゥゥゥゥゥッ
ほぼ駄目みたいですね
難しかったけどすごい楽しかったですこれ
???「いやっふぅ」
はい、という訳で最後のアトラクションなんですけども
こちら！
「スプラッシュU.F.O.」ということで
まあ見ての通りちょっとスプラッシュというか(?)
もう、何か水が。
お(熱)湯とかかかるんじゃないですかね
分かんないですけど。
ちょっと早速、乗っていきましょう。
はいという訳でこのアトラクションですね、
えと～私たちが
あの、焼きそばが作られる過程における
麺ーの気持ちになれるというアトラクションなんで
まずはここで洗浄されます。
ましっかり汚れを落とされるのが大事ですね
ぅわぁ洗浄ぉぉぉぉ！
お、スゴイスゴイ。
よし
ガイド) はぁ～い
ガイド) じゃあ工場警備
ガイド) よろしく頼んだぞぉぃってらっしゃ～い
よろしく頼まれましたー行って来ま～す
がっつりU.F.O.ですね
すーごいめっちゃ上あがりますよ
うぉぉぉぉ
怖ぁいよ
うをビックリした！
スゴイスゴイスゴイ
うをぁビックリっス
うわっ、うわっ、うわっ
うわっ、うわっ、わぁっ
おぉっ↑
うわぇぇぇぇっ！
あ、ほ、ほ、ほ、ほ、ほ、ほっ↑
あぁぁぁぁぁぅぅっ
はぉぉぉう↑
うばばば。
おっと。
あばじょぁがるーっ↑
あ、あ。
あっはっは怖かった...
機械) ...ｺｰｽﾆｹﾄﾗｰｶﾞｱﾗﾜﾚﾏｼﾀ
何？
機械) ﾎﾞﾀﾝｦﾚﾝﾀﾞｼﾃ､ｱﾌﾞﾗﾉｱﾝﾄﾞｦ150℃ﾆﾀﾓｯﾃｸﾀﾞｻｲ｡
ごめん、油の温度を150なゃんごぶぐるふぁざーはいはい。
あーヤバいこれ
来る来る来る
ぅわ、うわぁぁっ
うわっと
うわっ、うわ。
うわぁっとっとっとっとぅとぅぉぅぉぅぉぅぉぅぉ
おおーーーぉ
すげ、ヤカンがある。
おぉ～
うえぇぇぇ...
おおっ！
すっご！
めっちゃでけえ
あれ待って？
すごい匂いも良い方の匂いがする。
はいという訳で何かすごい
水が沢山かかったけど
ハラハラする楽しいアトラクションでした。
焼きそばの作る工程とかも何か
良く分かってすごい楽しかったです。
はいという訳で「グッジョバ!!」の
アトラクション色々回ってみたんですけども、
すごいあの久しぶりに
こういうちょっとテーマパークチックな所に
来れて個人的には楽しかったです。
だけど「グッジョバ!!」はですねその
普通に遊ぶアトラクション以外にも
どうやって物が出来てるかとかモノづくりのね
この...何か工程とかが色々分かるので。
ただ！遊ぶだけでなく、
勉強にもなります。
是非皆さん遊びに来て、ください。
そして「グッジョバ!!」はですねあの、
屋内のアトラクションなので、
雨が降ってても遊ぶことができます。
グッジョバヘルメットのおかげで良い動画が撮れました。
是非「グッジョバ!!」遊びに来てください。
じゃあな